Kigali the capital of Rwanda is a bit of
an outlier in something you might not
expect it's got one of the only large
capacity Indoor Sports Arenas in the
whole of
Africa that's something msai uiri
president of the NBA's Toronto Raptors
and the only African executive of a
North American sports franchise wants to
see more
[Music]
of so much of you're doing on the
continent specifically is focused on
infrastructure why is that I mean why is
it so important to you there's very very
few courts and basketball places for
people to play if I mention Acra Nairobi
Lagos Aban and even
Johannesburg there are no Arenas there's
not one Arena we don't see Sports as a
business we see it more as Recreation
we have to start getting business people
we have to start getting presidents we
have to start getting people that are
decision makers on the continent to
think about
[Music]
infrastructure in 2003 ujiri founded
Giants of Africa with the hope of
enriching the lives of Youth through
basketball in 2021 the organization
committed itself to Building 100
basketball courts on the
continent
and here in Kigali ujiri is touting the
BK Arena's transformation into zarya
court a destination complete with
restaurants and a hotel as an example
for the rest of the continent when I
look at scota Bank Arena I look at LA
Live and I look at the hotels the
restaurants the shops this is what
people want all those things around
those Place create you know like an
atmosphere where people people can grow
yeah and grow in a business
sense a lot of presidents are quick to
build stadiums rather than Arenas it's
hard to fill a a stadium if your name is
not Beyonce if your name is not Drake
yes or Taylor Swift yes Taylor Swift
exactly this can be filled up every
day do you want to take zarya Court
outside of Rwanda 100% yeah 100% this
was just the best template for us yeah
this set the tone set the
example if zarya court is going to be
the template architect kunle and Dame
will be the one charged with bringing
the best version of it to
life I met Messiah and uh we began
brainstorming ideas of what would
actually could happen here
and uh we developed a program of what
could be the combination of sports
hospitality and culture uh just based on
the needs of the city the needs of the
community and generally what the site
itself seems to have as a potential for
infrastructure there's a lot of existing
infrastructure that's here that I would
think would be knocked down and rebuilt
but you guys are kind of working with
what's already here why absolutely was
originally I think believe built as the
hostel for the sports uh uh Center so
you have that building which we decided
to maintain because it still has strong
bones and also a rich history we opened
up this space to create a an area for
multiports essentially uh so we're going
to have and there will be a roof over
this area and essentially it will be the
gateway to the sports city it's where we
envision people when they coming to for
game games they will um make a first
stop here they would socialize Hangouts
with family and friends and have a drink
so that's it's a day and night life uh
location financing wise I mean how do
you make this happen you know we have
investors that that are putting in um
Equity into the development and we have
uh our debt from a local bank here
because you know they see the potential
and the viability of the project and and
this is an important part of um
development of sports the business
aspect and and economic viability of
[Music]
it this is the 20th anniversary of GFA
and I saw you talking about how you're
not looking back you're looking forward
so Zaria this is this is the first
instance of it when you look forward 5
10 years I mean what what does the
sports ecosystem infrastructure on the
continent look like to you in a perfect
world I'm envisioning like talented
players playing on the continent yeah
I'm I'm envisioning leagues Africa's
biggest jewel is his talent it's his
people the challenges are going to come
from everywhere we have to learn how do
we find success here as Sports
[Music]
[Applause]
people